هذه الصور التي نشرها الجيش الاسرائيلي
لما قال انه نفق عثر عليه واستخدم لاحتجاز
اسرائيليين في خان
يونس هذا لا يزال فيلم
القسام هذا
النفق
اذا لواء فايز يعني كيف تعلق على هذه اص
يعني هذا النفق نعم نفق وجيد و يعني
تشطيبات الداخليه في بعض المحلات جيده لا
نقول غير ذلك لكن هذا النفق يبدو ضد ان لا
يفضي الى الانفاق كما قلت وهذا يؤكد بعد
ذهبت له قبل قليل لو كان هذا النفق يقدم
العمليات المستقبليه لا يمكن تدميره ولا
يمكن الاعلان عنه لكن هذا يعطينا شيء
معلومه على الاقل نستخدمها في البعد
التحليلي وهي هذه المعلومه تقول بان من
اشرف على اعداد وتنفيذ شبكات الانفاق لديه
قدره فائقه على التخطيط ولديه درجه عاليه
من الذكاء وبالتالي يعني حسب مقياس الذكاء
قد يصل لذكاءه ستاندرد العالمي 130 عالميه
لانه يبدو اعد شبكه الانفاق بحيث تخدم كل
جزء يخدم الجزء المخصص له الا الانفاق
الدفاعيه توظف لاغراض القتال ال الانفاق
اللوجستيه لاغراض اللوجستيه الانفاق
لاغراض التكديس لاغراض التكديس لاغراض
التصنيع وكل منها شبكه مستقله عن الاخرى
لا يوجد هناك ما يمكن الا يمكن عبر ممرات
سريه يمكن السيطره عليها واغلاقها
وبالتالي اي نفق يتم اكتشافه لا يفضي الى
كشف ما اهميه الكشف عن هذه الانفاق او هذه
الصور الان هم يقدموها على انها انجاز
ويحق لهم ان يقدموها اذا احتفلوا بالحصول
على صوره عن هويه محمد ضيف اذا اذا تحدثت
المذيعه واحمد الطيبي تحدث في الكنيست
بامكانكم ان تخرجوا من غزه لانكم عثرته
على فرده حذاء السنوار وعرضتها على شاشه
التلفزيون فمن يحتفل بتلك ليحتفل بهذه هذا
يعتبر بالنسبه لهم انجاز لكن هذا هذا
النفق ادى وظيفته كان لاغراض اداريه
استخدم لفتره وضعت فيها الرهائن عندما
اقتربت المعارك من هذه المنطقه تم نقل
الرهائن الى مكان اخر وقد يكونوا قتلوا
بالقصف الاسرائيلي لا نعلم وهو نفق من من
عده انفاق وهم قد اعترفوا بان هنا انا
اقول نفق لا يرتبط بشبكه انفاق القتال
القتال